the attack took place in the heart of
tel aviv targeting the ilka bar when it
was bustling with customers
the gunman from here escaped to jaffa
only a few kilometers away
but it took security services about nine
hours to find him and kill him on the
spot
and even if israel's security services
had been on high alert prime minister
naftali bennett said what he describes
as lone wolf attacks are difficult to
stop
terrorist attacks without an
organizational infrastructure are really
a major challenge for the security
system but it will withstand it our
enemies will look for every crack and
take every opportunity to attack us
we are in a difficult and challenging
time this might take time
just 10 days ago the prime minister had
called on israeli gun owners to carry
their weapons since then applications
for new licenses have rocketed even
though rules on firearms remain strict
civilians can only own one gun and up to
50 bullets
this comes at a time where israel is
inching closer to a political crisis
the prime minister's coalition has lost
its majority in parliament earlier this
week after a member of the knesset
defected his government is not about to
collapse yet but it's facing a major
challenge from israel's most acute
politician
benjamin netanyahu is believed to want
to make a comeback
this wave of attacks a perfect storm for
the former prime minister wanting to
reposition himself as mr security
he tweeted we are undergoing a wave of
terrorism with four attacks within a few
days a tough hand and a firm stance is
needed to restore peace and security to
the citizens of israel
bennett pledged there will be no
restrictions on israel's response to
this latest security challenge
that is a worry for palestinians with
the holy months of ramadan underway
one major checkpoint near jenin was shut
down indefinitely
palestinians living in the occupied west
bank now bracing themselves for more
raids detentions and possibly fighting
and death
al jazeera tel aviv